bonjour chers participants de notre
conférence primakov aujourd'hui nous
terminons notre projet de l'agencé
interfax nous avons eu six réunions en
ligne concernant les sujets les plus
aigus de la politique internationale du
point de vue des intérêts de la russie
aujourd'hui vous aurez la possibilité de
poser vos questions le président du
comité de l'organisation organisation
c'est l'aide du président de la russie
et nous avons eu l'aide de nos
partenaires de la chambre de commerce et
du centre de commerce international
aujourd'hui notre a invité spécial c'est
l'ami de la conférence primakov le
ministre des affaires étrangères sergueï
lavrov
cinq élèves ont finalement qui est pas
une seule de nos conférences ni en
russie ni à l'étranger et je lui suis
reconnaissant pour cela le ministre
respecte beaucoup cet héritage
diplomatique de monsieur primakov
comprendre cette tradition de monsieur
primakov c'est quelque chose que nous
partageons nous voyons ça comme un moyen
de transmettre leurs élèves
alors je vous donne la parole
merci avant tout je tiens à manifester
ma reconnaissance
d'avoir été invité à participer à ces
conférences primakov c'est une
tradition qui n'est pas très ancien mais
quelques mêmes jeunes mais qui fait
autorité dans et même si aujourd'hui
nous nous rencontrons en raison de
l'infection du nous rencontrons
aujourd'hui en format de visioconférence
en même temps cela permet de ne pas trop
cassé le graphique
mais encore une fois je remercie mes
collègues d'avoir organisé ces
précédentes réunions de ces conférences
primakov et sur les conséquences du
coronavirus si on a bien compris que
seules ses conséquences étaient
sensibles dans tous les domaines au
niveau économique partout au niveau
aussi des rencontres des échanges
culturels humanitaires économiques etc
et les appréciations qui nous donnons
concorde sur le fait qu' il faudra un
certain temps pour retrouver le rythme
normal le régime normal de des changes
mais tout cela nous sommes tous d'accord
sur le fait qu'il va y avoir des
conséquences certaines et que cela peut
affecter le système est l'appareil des
relations internationales la maladie
s'est manifesté heureusement dans des
dans une échelle relativement limitées
mais on sait qu'il ya des gens qui ont
personnellement souffert de cette
pantomime et tout le monde est bien
d'accord et là au niveau de toutes les
institutions
donc nous avons travaillé avec les les
citoyens russes qui se trouvaient à
l'étranger bloqués par la fermeture des
frontières et nous avons mis en place un
un état-major opérationnel qui travaille
avec la direction de l'aviation pour la
mise en place de listes et c'était un
travail particulièrement important il ya
eu bien évidemment des erreurs qui ont
été commises mais nous avons fait en
sorte de régler deux corées corriger ses
erreurs et il ya le système de paiement
de d'indemnités journalières pour les
personnes qui ont été victimes de ces de
cette situation aujourd'hui nous avons
passé l'essentiel de cette de cette
épreuve mais encore ces derniers jours
nous poursuivons l'analyse de cette
situation compte tenu des imprécisions
qui peut y avoir aujourd'hui pour
l'avenir mais de façon à ce que tout le
monde puisse entrer ici il y avait
évidemment d'autres aspects de sur
lesquels qui ont été affectés par cette
pandémie
et bien entendu il s'agit d'abord de
fait que cette pandémie
cette infection a suscité un certain
nombre de défis sur tous les plans de la
vie on a bien sûr réfléchit ça a été dit
au fait que les terroristes peuvent se
servir de cette situation pour susciter
de nouvelles menaces et parvenir à leurs
objectifs
malsain
il y a toujours la cyber criminalité et
d'autres menaces qui existent
et puis bien entendu il ya toujours les
conflits qui demeurent dans différents
points chauds du globe et tout cela
s'ajoute à un certain nombre de
difficultés qui s'ajoutent aussi au
travail de destruction et de sap à
l'encontre des systèmes de règlement des
conflits de maintien de la paix et des
institutions propres à protéger les
droits de l'homme et nous sommes
toujours convaincus que seul un travail
de concert peut permettre de résoudre
les problèmes dans le respect de la
charte de l'onu et par la mobilisation
et l'unification des efforts au sein du
g20 de traiter de shanghai
et ce n'est qu'à travers ces
organisations et ce travail mené en
commun que nous pouvons résoudre
ensemble les différents conflits qui se
pose aujourd'hui compte tenu des
préoccupations de chacun
malheureusement
dans ce contexte de pandémie tous ne
sont pas prêts à agir de façon
collective et nous constatons un certain
nombre de tentatives de tirer la
couverture à soi et d'utiliser la crise
pour étouffer les régimes qui ne
plaisent pas à imposer comme l'a dit
michelle bachelet représentant spécial
pour les questions des droits de l'homme
dans le contexte de pandémie imposer des
sanctions unilatérales constitue une
menace pour l'accès au besoin de mots
première nécessité pour les populations
et au lieu de penser à aider le
personnage le personnel médical on voit
des tentatives de d'accuser sert tous
telle ou telle personne telle ou telle
entité d'avoir diffusé cette pandémie
et comme il ya 75 ans après et ce n'est
que en une on en unifiant nos efforts
que nous avons réussi à vaincre le
nazisme
aujourd'hui il faut bien comprendre que
ce n'est qu'ensemble qu'en travaillant
ensemble que nous pouvons résoudre
l'ensemble des problèmes qui se posent
aujourd'hui on va parler des problèmes
de santé mais il y a aussi d'autres
problèmes qui doivent être résolus sur
la base de la charte de l'onu et de jeu
en se servant des plateformes de
discussion internationale et nos
collègues occidentaux je laisse dit à
maintes reprises cherche aujourd'hui à
mettre en place
sur le plan politique diplomatique et
pratiques internes
[Musique]
le terme de règles c'est à dire établir
de nouvelles règles et cela est une
tentative de ce restituer une part de
domination sur le monde et c'est une
tentative qui se manifeste notamment
dans la mise en place de groupes
d'intérêts où certains pays sont invités
qui partagent cette même volonté de
domination et qui cherchent à exercer
des pressions sur certains pays
tous ne sont pas invités dans c'est dans
ces groupes là certains sur l'essai de
côté et quand ce cercle et iii se réunit
qu'ils spéculent ça peut se faire par
exemple sur les armes chimiques ça peut
être sur la tentative d'un groupe d'élus
pour savoir qui sera coupable de
cybercriminalité est ensuite présenté ça
comme une règle universelle à appliquer
tout cela c'est un problème c'est une
problématique importante
et pour achever nos mots d'introduction
je dis que on voit que pour créer des
pour défendre les intérêts nationaux
certains pays mènent cette politique et
nous ce que nous proposons comme vous
l'avez remarqué c'est l'idée qui de
d'unir les efforts de tous et qui
beaucoup plus d'actualité aujourd'hui
c'est de travailler dans le cadre du
conseil de sécurité on voit que des
discussions qui sont très actives
actuellement n'est dans ces réunions
nous cherchons justement à avoir un
caractère déterminant est la dernière
chose que je voudrais dire à ce moment
c'est que toutes les difficultés qui se
manifestent aujourd'hui dans l'est
et aux relations internationales c'est
l'importance croissante de la communauté
des experts scientifiques politiques
pour analyser la situation et mettre en
place dès se servir de pronostics
raisonnable sur l'évolution de la
situation qu'ils puissent appliquer dans
notre activité commune mais au niveau de
la relation internationale et je
remercie les organisateurs des
conférences rybakov de nous permettre
justement d'avoir une vision plus
générale plus globale des problématiques
qui se posent aujourd'hui et qui nous
permettent de faire des d'être une force
de proposition pour le président donc je
vous remercie et je suis complètement à
votre disposition parole au secrétaire
d'état de l'état allié
russie-biélorussie merci chers experts
charme sur la mort juste quelques mots
pour développer ce que vient de dire
monsieur le ministre savait victorovitch
le rôle de la communauté des experts
l'importance du travail pratique dans
les affaires internationales et dans les
organisations comme la nôtre cette
unification intégrée de la russie la
biélorussie
non nous avons suivi cette cité et nous
avons célébré vantant dans l'existence
de notre état en organisant une grande
conférence scientifique nous avons été
surpris par le niveau de la demande pour
participer à cette conférence et nous
n'avons pas puis invité toutes les
personnes qui voulaient le faire nous
avons eu plus de 500 personnes
deux principales conséquences conclusion
que nous avons tirée c'est que d'abord
les positions du leader ont été gardés
donne la possibilité de réfléchir à ces
thèses et à ses projets de création et
de proposer quelque chose pour unifier
les populations moi je parle de mon
sujet qui est les relations russie
biélorussie
je voudrais attirer votre attention à
dos deux projets que nous sommes en
train de mettre en oeuvre c'est cette
saint pétersbourg en bourse et sept se
trouvent de haute vitesse c'est une idée
de business 13 innovative qui a eu une
grande réponse de la part des
institutions financières européennes qui
considère ce projet comme possiblement
le plus ambitieux pour l'europe beaucoup
voient une opportunité de participer à
ce projet deuxième chose la fédération
de russie a de plus en plus de soutien
pour cette idée surtout grâce au travail
du ministère des affaires étrangères et
au ministère des transports
deuxième sujet qui pourrait sembler un
peu particulier c'est l'utilisation des
ressources de l'arctique
cette idée attiré une grande attention
surtout de la part des jeunes chercheurs
biélorusses et russes et venant des
autres pays de la communauté d'états
indépendants
je voudrais aussi dire que c était une
fois la population les partagent ses
idées sont mises en oeuvre récemment en
accord sur la reconnaissance mutuelle
des visas a été signé le 19
joie mais sur la bofa a signé cet accord
sur l'utilisateur avaié pendant trois
ans c'est un moment clé du développement
de relations entre la russie et la
biélorussie
une fois les dés bien formulé une fois
seul et productive et rouge lui d'un
grand soutien
par exemple notre pro dispose des
propositions de créer un mémorial de
relève à l'époque a très vite trouvé d
un soutien surtout de la part du
ministère des affaires étrangères et des
autres institutions
récemment ce monument a été ouvert je
voudrais demander un comité d'experts de
nous proposer vos idées
nous allons les considérer essayer de
les mettre en oeuvre et suivre cette
idée est simple que nous pouvons le
faire on devons croire en nos forces qui
nous devons faire ce que nous pouvons
merci merci grégory alex ich pour votre
optimisme de nos sessions maintenant nos
paso aux questions des participants de
la conférence prime à la sagaie
victorovitch il ya cinq ans dans le
pronostic globale que nous avons fait
l'un des quatre scénarios de l'autre
mondiale pouvait être la nouvelle
bipolarité
à l'époque pour penser ainsi nous avons
vu cette puissance des états unis de la
chine
la pandémie a confirmé cette hypothèse
on voit qu'il ya une bipolarité
asymétrique
on voit cet écart entre la russie les
états unis avec la chine entre la chine
et les états unis donc ma question est à
votre avis est ce que dans le conflit
entre la chine et les états unis
le moment de pouvoir autant revenir est
déjà arrivé et la deuxième question est
ce que la russie pourrait devenir une
puissance qui servent à retrouver
l'équilibré dans le système mondial et
pouvez vous répondre en vous posant sur
votre expérience de la diplomatie
multilatérale
merci merci je me souviens effectivement
ceux de se prononcer que vous avez
rappelé je mets chose à dire que ces
cinq dernières années
beaucoup de choses ont changé
premièrement sur le plan que
se trouve confirmée cette confrontation
appelez la comme vous voulez cette
opposition entre la chine et les états
unis elle ne fait que croître
donc ce n'est pas seulement un processus
bipolaire mais cette situation dans
l'ensemble est beaucoup plus complexe
aujourd'hui et elle devient plus beaux
multipolaire aujourd'hui et il ya un
certain nombre d'acteurs en dehors de la
chine et des états unis qui c'est d'une
façon ou d'une autre de promouvoir leurs
priorités et je pense que tout cela est
complexe et nous parlerons encore des
possibilités d'évolution
comme l'a dit monsieur kaloga neuf dans
un journal dans le journal la russie
dans la dans la politique internationale
mais on comprend bien que toute cette
diversité des aspects des facteurs
politiques militaires historiques qui
s'accumulent aujourd'hui et qui avait
annoncé déjà monsieur primakov doivent
être prises en compte dans notre travail
et ce à partir de ce prisme là à travers
ce prisme là que nous devons considérer
ces oppositions et tout cela seconde est
confirmée par le fait que chaque partie
y cherchent de plus en plus à recruter
des partisans
voilà ça selon le voit par exemple dans
le domaine de l'eau et metz mais aussi
dans d'autres sujets qui sont
aujourd'hui associé à la prise de
position contradictoires entre les états
unis et la chine
on comprend bien que ce processus
de puissance de l'état par exemple en
chine est perçu par les américains comme
une menace alors volonté de préserver
leur domination mondiale
les dés 2010 est déjà la puissance de la
chine à côté de celle de la russie était
présenté par les américains comme une
menace et donc il y avait même une
bataille de priorité entre la chine et
les états unis pour les à minc et nous
la chine et la russie nous étions
accusés d'être une menace pour
l'intégrité et la prospérité des états
unis et le comprenons bien aujourd'hui
que les états unis lou mène de cette
bataille en recourant à des moyens qui
ne sont pas toujours honorables et en
utilisant des méthodes qui ne servent
que leurs intérêts nationaux
c'est compréhensible mais certains
instruments sont utilisés de façon
unilatérale comme les sanctions et tout
cela dégénère rapidement en sous forme
d'ultimatum de guerre commerciale et c
est par exemple les l'accord qui avait
été conclu en janvier entre les
etats-unis et la chine est très
révélateur mais washington accuse non
seulement la chaîne de volet d'aidé de
l'emploi en réalité mais aussi
d'aménager une un meeting hier de
d'approvisionnement avec un mécanisme
qui s'impose à l'ensemble de l'économie
internationale mais aussi les américains
accusent les chinois de diffuser de
fausses informations sur le coronavirus
les accuse d'espionnage commercial et
industriel et et les états unis refusent
de travailler avec huawei et les autres
sociétés donc met de côté les sociétés
chinoises dans le domaine des hautes
technologies
il exécute de d'expansionnisme dans
l'asie du sud est
il accuse les chinois de de ne pas
respecter l'inde le tibet hong kong etc
tout cela
tout cela se manifeste
simultanément et cherche à montrer que
toutes ces pressions cherche ne font que
montrer que les américains cherchent à
rappeler leur position dominante sur les
états unis j'espère que ont des gens qui
sont capables quand la campagne
électorale sera passée que sont capables
de réfléchir de façon sensée et
le ministère américain des finances
secrétaire d'état américain aux finances
avait dit encore une fois qu'il fallait
pas franchir certaines frontières à
propos de la politique du dollar
sur le plan monétaire international il
ya bien sûr un espoir que bien sûr les
chinois lors diplomatie politique qui
cherche toujours à éviter les situations
de crise mais il ya quand même des
signes plutôt inquiétant c'est que
malgré ces espoirs qu'on peut nourrir
c'est que des représentants
officiellement chinois et américains
passent aux attaques personnelles sous
une forme très grave et je dirais que
tout cela est un facteur de tension d'un
côté comme de l'autre et ce degré de
tension très inquiétant mais j'espère
malgré tout que nos amis américains et
chinois de hon encore des réserves de
diplomatie et en évitant de s'insulter
l'un l'autre de s'accuser l'un l'autre
dans de tous les péchés comme les
américains le fait à chaque coin de rue
mais pour reconnaître sont capables de
reconnaître que la chine est une grande
puissance et et seront respectés le fait
que toutes grandes puissances a le droit
et à la possibilité de se manifester que
2 encore une fois le monde ne doit être
capable de travailler en esprit de corps
et de coopération entre ces différentes
super elle puisse superpuissance
encore une fois je pense que tout cela
ne répond pas encore
à nos intérêts je pense que l'union
européenne ait et les autres pays on
comprenne bien que les échanges
commerciaux entre la chine et l'union
européenne et sont à peu près
équivalents aux échanges entre la chine
et les états unis et en ce qui concerne
l'autonomie stratégique de l'union
européenne qui est ne concerne pas
seulement les questions militaires de
sécurité mais aussi les questions de
commercial et je pourvoi que l'union
européenne cherche aussi à faire revenir
autant que possible la position sur son
propre territoire et remettre en place
les chaînes de production pour être
compétitif avec les américains c'était
en faisant revenir tous les processus
d'essai sur son territoire je pense que
tout cela va créer un certain nombre de
tensions et de conflits d'intérêts
mais contrairement à l'aneth 2014 quand
le nom européenne sous la forte pression
américaine avait imposé des sanctions à
l'égard de la russie
on voit quand même des manifestations de
bon sens en union européenne
et je veux dire à l'égard de doux la
russie on voit qu'un certain nombre de
dirigeants européens appellent à revenir
vos os revenir sur les cinq principes de
relations avec la russie qui va est
énoncée par federica gagner quelques
années et qui appelle à revenir à une
responsabilité plus grande nous avait
des intérêts de le néant père
donc on a parlé de l'union européenne et
de l'est la chine maintenant l'union
européenne est là aussi et josette borel
qui est représentant spécial de la
politique extérieure de l'union
européenne disait récemment une question
portant sur les sanctions qui pourraient
être imposées à la chine à l'égard de je
ne sais plus quoi d'ailleurs c'est le
patient pourtant et il avait dit que ce
n'est pas la méthode à laquelle nous
devons utiliser et et nous avons le
savoir si les sanctions pouvaient donc
un bon outil qui puisse être utilisé à
l'égard de la russie de la question
était que la réponse était que il
fallait réfléchir
donc il s'agissait de sanctions sur
l'à-propos de hong kong des droits de
l'homme c'est donc ici il ya beaucoup de
l'évolution possible et nous sommes
prêts à travailler avec eux d'une open
en faveur de pas en défaveur de qui que
ce soit mais simplement sur la base du
pragmatisme et des du respect des
intérêts mutuels et j'espère que nous
saurons maîtriser cette myopie politique
de l'union européenne et qu'elle l'urban
sera accordé plus d'attention à
traitement des problèmes qui se posent
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir développer la
coopération économique et commerciale je
vois pas davantage pour la russie deux
dans une guerre commerciale ni vis-à-vis
de l'union européenne vis-à-vis de
l'inde avec laquelle nous avons des
relations d'amitié je rappelle encore
une fois que nous avons un partenariat
privilégié particulier et spécial c'est
le terme utilisé à l'égard de nab est
donc pour nous c'est important de
préserver ce partenariat
merci ce qui est victorieuse pour votre
réponse exhaustive
je donne la parole je me suis ragots
etats unis canada
merci victor
nous avons déjà évoqué les relations
russo américaines du développement de
ces relations dépendent aussi la
sécurité internationale la stabilité
stratégique
la situation étant qui tente
étant donné que les régimes du contrôle
sur les armements est en crise profonde
aujourd'hui
il est possible que six mois plus tard
ce sera d'exister le dernier traité clé
dans ce domaine est la raison surtout
les raisons de cette situation sont
nombreuses
il y a des raisons géopolitiques
technologique mais à mon avis les jets
de constater que l'opinion publique
je ne fais pas aujourd'hui de pression
sur les élites politiques pour contrôler
les armements qu'on s'était à l'époque
des démonstrations de masse aujourd'hui
pour les opinions publiques les
problèmes clés c'est la pandémie et le
changement climatique le terrorisme et
la peur d'une guerre nucléaire n'est
plus une priorité dans ce dans cette
perspective peut-on changer la situation
où il faudra encore une crise de cuba
crise de mes cils pour pour que
l'opinion publique soit exprimé deuxième
chose ensemble avec nos collègues de la
communauté scientifique
nous organisons beaucoup de conférences
par
somme avec des experts américains
vous savez dit qu'en amérique il ya
quand même des gens qui peuvent
réfléchir d'une manière raisonnable et
ses conférences nous donne une
possibilité de travailler sur un nombre
de propositions qui pourraient être
utilisés dans le cadre de nos
initiatives nous informant de cette
proposition vient ministère et surtout
ça y est lavrov mais à présent à mon
avis il faudrait réfléchir plutôt à des
actions radicales de notre part
peut-être dans le cadre du sommet du
groupe nucléaire de cinq pays
peut-être en vue de créer des conditions
permettant non seulement de prévenir le
la force du système du contrôle des
armements mais aussi par le temps de
formuler une nouvelle un nouveau système
de la stabilité stratégique qui pourrait
correspondre au 20e siècle
merci je suis d'accord avec vous que les
risques nucléaires existent qu'ils ont
augmenté ces dernières années qu'il ya
des menaces pour la sécurité et la
stabilité stratégique
tout cela y constate une détérioration
de la situation certains veulent
s'assurer une domination mondiale et
s'assurer la victoire sur ce jusque dans
ce qu'ils appellent la concurrence entre
les superpuissances
donc c'est plutôt une conque une
concurrence
stratégique et on voit une destruction
systématique de l'ensemble des
instruments qui assure la l'entente et
la sécurité et tout cela permet de leur
libérer
leur laisser plus de liberté de
manoeuvre et tout cela est d'intervenir
à tout coin du globe tout seul
intervient sur fond de modifications
doctrinale et aujourd'hui les etats unis
[Musique]
n'excluent pas un usage ponctuel d'armes
nucléaires et je vous rappelle que dans
l'accord de stabilité stratégique
ils disent que c'est dans notre
stratégie à nous que cet emploi
ponctuelle est prévu c'est à dire une
escalade point de vue pour une
désescalade et disques dans nos derniers
l'an dernier dokht doctrine stratégique
certains points caché secret envisagent
de telles positions c'est pas vrai
et encore une fois on a une
matérialisation de ces de ce potentiel
technique et ne sait très bien que
l'augmentation du potentiel militaire
d'armes à moyenne portée ne cesse
d'augmenter
et sur le fond de tout cela la situation
plutôt inquiétantes ont ces deux
dernières années de retrait américain de
ces accords
il faut pas oublier que tout cela peut
avoir des conséquences graves et donc ça
fait donc deux ans la formule que nous
avions proposé à l'époque qui se réfère
à ce qu'avaient dit les dinos fait
roosevelt à l'époque des américains
disent qu'ils vont encore regarder entre
parenthèses je dirais simplement que nos
en étant en étant à bicloo il ya des
journalistes qui sont je dirais que ce
thème
il n'est pas possible de remporter une
guerre en utilisant l'armé nucléaire
mais l'essentiel c'est que la
formulation n'est pas plus faible que ce
qui avait été stipulé dans les documents
correspondants signé par l'urss à
l'époque et les états unis et donc
l'affaiblissement de ses formulations
montre que les les américains voudraient
bien détruire ce caractère irréfragable
delà de ses dispositions
aujourd'hui une attention qui est
accorder à ces menaces aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il faut être d'autant plus
vigilant et s'exprimer de façon claire
sur ces aspects qui sont par certains
côtés assez technique
la façon dont ils sont formulés mais il
faut que l'opinion publique soit
informée
il faut compter pas seulement sur les
structures officielles des états mais
met aussi que la la communauté civile
soit 1 d'informer que les experts les
scientifiques suivent tout cela et pour
confirmer cette position j'appellerai
également à ne pas exagérer ne pas
dépasser les bornes dans la prise en
conscience de la menace nucléaire
il s'était dit qu'il faut pas aller trop
dans un sens et jouer le jeu de ceux qui
veulent susciter la panique dans ce sens
là donc l'accord qui avait été
le signer l'accord qui avait été signé
sur la sécurité est aujourd'hui malmenée
aujourd'hui on peut trouver des
parallèles mais à ce propos ce que je
veux dire à propos des des des masses il
faut bien comprendre ce que quand trump
a été élu par exemple donc nous avions
soutenu sont ni des savantes et de
normaliser les relations avec les états
unis
mais ce qui est important c'est de
continuer à travailler en direct avec
les maintenir en contact direct avec les
puissances nucléaires
ce qu'il faudrait c'est que le bon sens
domine donc vous avez parlé de
consultations régulières entre nous les
experts les américains et nous nous
saluons ce ces dispositions parce que
les appréciations que nous obtenons de
nos experts après consultation sont
toujours prises en compte et permettent
de déterminer nos approches et les
différentes évolutions possibles de la
situation qui sont proposés sont
toujours analyser les différents
scénarios et chacun d'eux est étudiée
ensuite concerne un sommet des cinq
puissances et sajoo pris effectivement
de le garder entre 12 ce qui est à
l'ordre du jour ici c'est qu'est -ce de
l'idée de soumettre le groupe des cinq
pays membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité
cette idée
états unis cherche on cherche à utiliser
cela est sous leur autorité aussi les
anglais et les français ils veulent
élargir ce groupe de discussion autour
des armes nucléaires donc la chine a
exposé plusieurs fois sa position est
d'ailleurs les parmi nos interventions
et les américains tirent de façon
totalement irrespectueuse uniquement ce
qu'ils veulent utiliser ils font pareil
avec les déclarations les chinois comme
les chinois ont dit pas où nous sommes
prêts à participer aux discussions
dès que les américains réduiront leur
arsenal
au niveau des miens et et le lendemain
les américains dié nous sommes heureux
de voir que les chinois sont prêts à
discuter avec nous et qu'il vienne à
vienne nos consultations d'experts pour
discuter sur ces questions fin juin et
l'à une nouvelle fois ils disent nous
nous appelons nous invitons les chinois
à parvenir
et alors que j'ai eu une rencontre à
deux auraient permis de discuter mais on
voit que même les appréciations que nous
donnons nous en partant du fait que les
états unis que la chine et non c'est
même sa proposition si il ya une
approche multilatérale qui était et
étudier de façon générale or les
américains je note n'ont rien énoncé par
écrit sur le papier au moins qu'ils
énoncent une fois par écrit et ça il ne
vole pas catégoriquement hydro il refuse
catégoriquement
nous ne disons nous sommes prêts à parme
a discuté de façon multilatérale
mais que chacun manifeste volontairement
ses intentions mais toutes ces réserves
et il dit simplement la russie soutient
nos discussions multilatérales et nous
nous considérons qu'il faut commencer
que la france et la grande bretagne
veulent participer et bellick sli a
déclaré encore récemment en répondant à
une question il a dit c'est pas notre
discuter c'est la france à la
grande-bretagne de décider mais en tout
cas pour la pour la chine eux ils
imposent leur position donc ici on a sur
le traité new start
il ya même une discussion qui s'est mise
en place
notre ambassadeur et un coffre parler de
ces questions et il était question de
mettre en place trois groupes de travail
donc fin juillet il y aura des
discussions à vienne sur l'espace sur le
transport sur et sur la doctrine
militaire
nous allons voir ce qui va se passer
mais nous ne refusons jamais de discuter
il nous allons faire en sorte que ce
dialogue soit constructif
merci ce qu'est victorovitch sa galaxie
beach nous a parlé en détail de son
voyage à vienne